good morning everyone I like to show you
one of my favorite games played by
Michelle tall it was played in Stuttgart
in a simultaneous exhibition in 1969
it's all explained white and his
opponent is black
his opponents name is a sweety dog
although I don't know the first name so
let's see the game efore c5 is still in
the sense right there 3 d6 d4 C takes d4
Knight takes d4 Knight to f6 Knight to
c3 g6 transposes
French holding into the Sicilian dragon
Bishop to e3 Bishop to g7 f3 towel is
preparing us all attack
Knight to c6 Queen to d2 or preparing to
exchange the dark squared Bishop Bishop
to d7 queenside castle Queen to a5 King
to be one route the c8 and here a Tau
starts his form rush g4 h 6 and the
decision six movies is already a bit
dubious as but can ever castle again
point to h4 and now a six black is
preparing to push his own pawns on the
Queen side Bishop - G - nice - e5 and
here
a black skinned is still in the center
so you think that tau probably wouldn't
attack on the Kings side and you would
be wrong let's all play g5 and here we
have h takes g5 and tall captures HD g5
and black captures the rook rook takes
MH 1 but here tall doesn't recapture the
rook in fact he takes pawn takes and s6
and here a black takes the other rook
rook takes and e1 and in here you can
see if the Queen takes the rook
like we'll simply capture the s6 bone
and towel is Donna repented and the
exchange but here tell plays a very
funny move Knight takes on d1 and opens
up the attack on the black screen so
black captures the Queen and here tower
captures context and g7 and in this
position black resigned because there is
no move he can play tall is threatening
a pawn to g8 m8 promoting to Queen and
checkmate in his opponent and the queen
is attacked is if black plays any other
mood for example I don't know Bishop day
six the make room for ask install we'll
simply promotes to Queen check after the
King moves he will take the rook and
after the King takes that will capture
the Queen finally and he is up to pieces
so yeah this is one of my favorite their
favorite miniatures by the great Michal
towel and I hope you enjoyed it if you
have a favorite game of your own be sure
to let me know in the comment section
below see you soon